[Music]
let's add to the scenery let's bring in
Albert Greer the senior NFL reporter
lead content strategist for the Monday
Morning Quarterback he's just known as
the Monday Morning Quarterback in my
opinion kind enough to join us I know I
know what scenery you're adding to
Japanese yeah if you're one too okay
um yeah it's interesting you asked about
Travis Kelsey I asked Chad Henny about
that because I I had um you can pull
that microphone a little bit closer to
you I had seen on Twitter like you see
over and over again like hey you might
want to cover 87 right so I like after
like the divisional game I I asked Chad
honey I'm like so like what is it like
how come no one can get obviously he'd
be the number one priority for any
defense yeah and Chad hammy said it's
because he was a high school quarterback
and Travis Travis Kelsey was a high
school quarterback and Chad said he sees
the field like a quarterback so he sees
the field the same way Mahomes does so
he knows how to set up coverage he knows
how to set a Defender up he knows how to
use their leverage against them yeah
it's because he played quarterback in
high school he sees the field
differently than a lot of other skill
players yeah so there you go he's one of
those guys though that you're right I
don't know if there's a true definition
of why is he so great but you know that
kind of puts it into perspective of a
football player seeing it and plus I
always wondered about that if you were a
defensive back or a wide receiver and
you played quarterback in high school
how does that help you see the field and
you know that certainly pertains to
Travis Kelsey all right a lot to get to
anything come out of media night that
the audience should be aware of no okay
fair enough thanks for joining us Albert
Greer everybody appreciate it honestly
though like that's not really for us
right like no it's not I mean I like
look I I think one thing that is
noticeable is is the amount like is the
infrastructure of both teams right like
and you see okay like there is Shane
steichen and Jonathan Gannon future head
coaches on The Eagles staff and then you
look at the chief staff and they're
established coordinators and Eric
bienemy and Steve spagnolo and then you
see further down the line guys like
Brian Johnson and Kevin Patullo who
probably are on a head coach trajectory
so I think one thing you saw like the
depth of the rosters the depth the
coaching steps the depth of the scouting
staffs like it really is two
organizations that really have a lot of
things working
when Nick siriani took over and had that
initial press conference we goofed on
him yep
um I could now all of a sudden he's
found his voice he's found out who he is
here what's the what led him to this
point I think it's I actually think like
looking back at it now well I had a
similar experience with Nick like the
first time I got him on the phone I
didn't know him at all and this was when
he was the Colts offensive coordinator
and it was like a 10 minute phone call
where it was like pulling teeth talking
to him you know what I mean like it felt
like I couldn't get anything out of him
was awkward it was weird and then you
know I I got to actually meet him in
person and it was totally different and
I think like one of the things like what
you see like with and what we all saw in
that first press conference is actually
part of his greatest strength he's
comfortable in his own skin yeah I don't
care what other people think about him
and I I've said this to a lot of
different people like he might be the
most normal guy among the 32 NFL head
coaches and I think then you look at his
staff and they're all guys who are in
the same age range and they all have
kids who are the same age and then the
atmosphere that creates in the building
where everybody's sort of all in and
everybody's sort of on the same page and
I just I think he's found a way to
create an environment that is remarkable
it sounds weird remarkably normal and I
think the players because of that like
coming to work every day so you have and
I I've had people there say this to me
like the weight room is full at 6 a.m
you know what I mean it's stuff like
that like where no one ever sees it but
it's again kind of about like an
organization all pulling in One
Direction I think a huge part of that is
Nick's own personality in that
people rally around him because he's a
normal guy you know what I mean like and
it's just you know I I think the worst
thing you can be as a head coach is
somebody who's trying to be somebody
else or somebody who's trying to project
you know Nick is unapologetically
himself and obviously it's worked you
got some coaching vacancies yeah I
didn't know if they're vacant because
you have coaches in the Super Bowl who
they might be considering let's start
here in Arizona why is this job still
open
I I bet a couple people say to me that
maybe the owner likes the fact that
people are talking about his team during
Super Bowl week so that was one theory
that this has been dragged out this way
like because it's part of it is is this
a positive thing that you don't have a
head coach well that that people are
talking about the Cardinals you know so
I mean any publicity is good publicity I
mean guess the old Jerry Jones thing
right like you know three minutes on
ESPN's three minutes on ESPN what has
this come down to who wants to coach
Kyler Murray I I don't think it's so
much that like I do think part of it is
that they they hired a general they
wanted to hire their general manager
first and so they hired Monte Austin for
it this is also the first time they've
sort of gone outside of their family to
do an entirely new like setup right like
so if you look at it you go back to Mike
Bidwell got the team from his dad or
control like 0708 so when they were
hiring you know wizard hunt well they'd
already had a sitting general manager in
Rod Graves and they hired they fired
those two guys they promote Steve kind
Steve Keim hires Bruce Arians and then
when they fire or when Bruce Arians
walks away
time hires Wilkes then Keim hires
Kingsbury they've never really done this
before and so like I think that that's a
part of it
um and yeah I mean I think you know like
a huge piece of it was sort of figuring
out what they want and so
um you know I think that the the fact
that this is dragged out a little bit
does open up the possibility though and
I know a lot of people are on the league
think that is the potential there that
if they're dragging this out so if it
doesn't work with they're talking to
Mike Kafka the Giants offensive
coordinator today they were supposed to
talk to Brian Flores tomorrow Flora is
backed out because he took the Vikings
DC job and then Luann arumo the Bengals
DC on Friday are they dragging us out so
if they're not enamored with Kafka today
or in a rumo on Friday that now they can
talk to the Eagles coordinators on
Monday and uh they missed the window to
talk to the Eagles coordinators the
first time around which meant they
weren't allowed to talk to them during
the Eagles bye week so they have to wait
till Monday if they want to talk to
Jonathan Gannon or she and steiken I put
JJ Watt in uncomfortable spot yesterday
I didn't ask him I did ask him about
Tyler Murray
he kept asking me what I thought of
Kyler Murray and I I just I don't know
what the sense the feeling is I I said
to JJ White I said look Kyler Murray had
it so easy in high school and you know
he goes to Oklahoma and had it easy
there you know in that offense there yep
uh played baseball I mean everything
came to him naturally yeah but but you
know playing quarterback in the NFL is
not hey I got the most ability Patrick
Mahomes has unbelievable ability but
he's he's a leader right and puts in the
time and that's like what do you hear
about Kyler Murray
I like I think that the if you're if if
he's the guy that like you're looking to
like he hasn't been the guy to set the
tone for the rest of the organization
and that's been problematic for them you
know and so like if you want your
quarterback to be sort of the head of
the snake right like in the guy who is
going to put natural peer pressure on
everybody else to work their ass off and
to be the first one in the building and
to set the tone for the entire
organization he hasn't been that and it
really goes back to who he is and I
actually think it relates to his
baseball background like the huge the
big knock on him coming out of Oklahoma
was well he's a baseball player so he's
sort of an independent contractor and
like he wasn't part of spring practice
in college as a quarterback which is
different because of baseball and so
like it's always been for Kyler Murray
it's not that he doesn't work hard it's
that like a lot of his work is directed
differently than it is for other
quarterbacks so he's not around as much
and he's not going to be the guy who's
pulling everybody in the same direction
now in his defense like he did get the
guys together in Texas in the off season
that sort of thing
but when your quarterback isn't showing
up for half the off-season program
that's a problem you know what I mean
because now well are there a bunch of
other third and fourth and fifth year
players who are going to see that as
licensed hey I'm going to stay in
Florida in in April and man I'm going to
show up June 1st and how does that sort
of flow into the summer when you're
starting training camp and then he's
probably not going to start the season
right because
ACL yeah and so how much of his ACL
recovery is going to be done here like
and how all in is he going to be with a
new coach and I think that's part of
like the equation when you're looking at
it Dan like I if you're if you have if
you if you're Mike Kafka or you're you
have one shot at being a head coach
right see because most most guys don't
get a second shot and you can have one
shot at being a head coach
like what do you have two or three years
the contract dictates that it's going to
be really hard to walk away from Kyler
Murray for that period yeah so that's
part of the equation coming here is that
it's you almost have to find a way to
make it work with Kyler which is sort of
what Sean Payton's facing in Denver with
Russell Wilson too uh Albert Breer the
Monday Morning Quarterback joining us uh
Tom Brady said yesterday that he's going
to take the year off yeah
um do you think he does TV
I'm not convinced I'm not convinced that
he's gonna I mean
I will say that I think if he does do TV
he's gonna I think he'll go all in and
try to be really good at it
um I'm not convinced that he does it um
just because I do think that
I hate to say it's beneath him
but but doesn't it sort of sort of you
like like
can you guys see him like standing in
the buffet line with the rest of us at
halftime
waiting in line to take a peek
anybody got kale can I get some kale
around here some avocados like it really
wasn't it was never hard for me to wrap
my head around the idea of Tony Romo
doing that right it's not even hard to
like wrap your head around the idea of
Troy doing that you know what I mean
like it's hard to wrap it around the
idea of Tom Brady standing in that line
yeah waiting for a hot dog yeah you know
what I mean so
um I do think like you got to look at
the Mannings and what they're doing or
you have to look larger than that like
Elway got into ownership yeah it feels
like Tom is more of the guy who greets
you in his suite and he's the owner and
or you know part of an ownership I mean
like is it Magic Johnson is that his
future you know what I mean like I just
feel like
to satisfy his competitive like that
because I think that's what one I think
one of the big reasons one of the things
that most people miss about him I think
one of the things that kind of kept him
going was the fear of losing that outlet
the competitive Outlet because he is
such a maniac when it comes to
competition and like I don't think it
was ever searching for a fairy tale
ending or getting back at people in New
England improving people I think for him
it was like a like an addiction almost
to competition and I do think like going
and being part of an ownership group and
getting into team building might satisfy
that to a degree would television
satisfy that
if he goes to the games right then you
prepare for both teams you're preparing
for both defenses and that I think would
get those competitive juices flowing
yeah it's it's what Drew Brees missed
out on right he was in the studio and
there's no magic in the studio you got
to create Magic the game creates magic
and therefore you go out there then you
feed off that excitement right and
therefore I think that would work with
Brady but I'm just shocked that he's not
doing anything for Fox this week and I
thought send a camera crew to Tampa and
just say Tom I want you to prepare for
both of these defenses and I want you to
talk about both of these quarterbacks so
I got you know him in the film room
breaking things down doesn't have to be
out here doesn't have to be on the set
right but you can kind of bring him into
the fox family and it'd be a great dry
run for him to see what it's like you
know what I mean like it's an It's
relatively it's not heavy lifting you
know you can get a couple of takes
you're gonna make sure he looks great
you could stop it and say all right
let's try it again you're not live TV
nobody's going to be judging you we
talked about this before it still feels
like if you wanted somebody to be
themselves because you're always here
hey just be yourself Troy Aikman said to
Tom his advice hey just be yourself the
one guy who could be himself as an
analyst who's not employed as an analyst
is who
Jay Cutler yeah yeah yeah yeah
I mean I think Cutler like he doesn't
care right I I honestly thought I felt
this way all along like I think Cutler
like she had the deal to do it right
like he had to deal with Fox and then
Tannehill tears up his knee and Adam
gase gets him to come to Miami for 10
million bucks I like I think Jay Cutler
would have been the guy who is a he's
intelligent
and B he doesn't give a crap what anyone
thinks like he doesn't care like he's
not looking he wouldn't be in the booth
looking down like oh well I got beers
with the Right Guard out there like
three weeks ago so I can't say anything
no like he wouldn't care you know so
um yeah I think Cutler would have been
really I just think it'd be hard because
Tom spent his entire life not
criticizing or saying anything right and
now you're gonna say Tom be yourself go
out there and critique yeah you know be
honest I just don't see you know him
wanting to do that I just yeah I just
don't know where I mean that's the thing
is like I also like sort of look at him
and how many different ways has he
compromised you know what I mean like
it's like with everything because he's
been so image conscious for his entire
NFL career and part of it is like you
know like I think he looks at like okay
like I'm invested with this person and
he's incredibly loyal
is he compromised you know what I mean
like where it's just he can criticize
this person but then I can't criticize
that and that can be really really
tricky you know did you hear Belichick
on his podcast
yeah it was a Love Fest he was gushing
yeah well have you ever heard Belichick
talk about Lawrence Taylor yes I mean
like yes he really loves Lawrence I I
had to like I can remember
um talking to Drew Bledsoe about this
right
so you know Drew obviously had a really
ugly exit from New England and it was
tough and it was something that it took
years for him to reckon with right
and um Drew told me he's like so I think
it was when he went back for the Patriot
Hall of Fame induction he hadn't seen
Belichick since and um and so
you know so he goes back to Foxboro and
he and and he still gets got along great
with Robert Kraft like it was crafts
first quarterback everything like that
he knew that would be great and
everything but he was actually like True
Blood is a former NFL quarterback was
nervous about going back and seeing bill
and uh and Drew told me like you know so
he walks in and they have a stadium
practice the weekend of the uh for
season ticket holders the the weekend of
the uh of the of the um ceremony
and Drew walks out on the field and Bill
comes walking over to him he gives him a
hug and likes like warm as like can be
and Drew said he was like sat there
silent for like two minutes
but I think that's part of it is like
when you like bill is so good at
compartmentalizing so you're either as
professional and I've heard this from so
many people you're either in your
professional life or you're in his
personal life and once guys retire they
get moved like they're like like from
one category to the next and I'm sure
that's what it is it's like as long as
as long as time was in the NFL he's part
of Bill's professional life yeah which
is part of Bill's personal yeah I think
he likes you uncomfortable when you play
for him or you're not quite sure
um Lamar Jackson's playing for who next
year
I think the Ravens but I'm less sure of
it than I was a year ago um if not the
Ravens
you want to say the Dolphins because
there's so many natural reasons for it I
I I I believe the Dolphins when they say
like they want to give it another run
with Tua I think the problem that the
Dolphins run into is that fifth year
option they've got to make a decision on
the fifth year option there's the
concussion issue and that's a 25 to 30
million dollar decision and if you pick
up his option those are fully guaranteed
now you're locking yourself into two for
2024. if you don't pick it up now you're
in a year-to-year proposition with your
you're in a year-to-year situation with
your quarterback so does that make you
view it differently and if the
opportunity to trade for a Lamar Jackson
comes along do you look at it and say
well this might make some more sense for
us you know so I I think the issue is
like how you bridge the gap if like
between like so the Ravens are willing
to give him a top of the market
traditional quarterback deal
Lamar wants a DeShaun Watson deal so
like how do you kind of like how do you
how do you bridge the two and they've
been unable to do it and I think
Lamar like you can understand why the
Ravens would be hesitant you can also
sort of understand Lamar's point of view
where it's like
I put my body on the line for five years
for you
and now you're asking me for injury
protection three years from now like you
know what I mean if you were Lamar
seriously though like you act like look
what you put me like you have put an
unprecedented amount of stress on my
body as a quarterback never has a
quarterback been deployed that way ever
right run that much ever right and I did
that for five years for you and now
you're asking me to sign a contract
that's going to protect you three years
from now so if all if I have to pay the
price for all this you aren't going to
have to pay that price with me
I don't think this is about the money
for Lamar I think this is principle like
I felt that way because he thinks about
these things differently if it was about
money he would have just taken the deal
that's a lot of you know if this was
just a financial decision he finished
the last two years injured just take the
contract get your 150 million guaranteed
and be dealt with it you know I think
for for Lamar like I really believe this
about him like he's always done things
differently and I do think this is about
principle for him he's Albert Greer the
Monday Morning Quarterback thank you for
all your contributions the entire season
yeah absolutely we love when you're
going on in the off season yes that'd be
awesome uh Albert Greer the Monday
Morning Quarterback we'll take a break
here we got our play of the day up next
Dan Patrick Show